the closest to religion religious  experience for me would be will be  football and it and what it gives you is  a deep sense of kind of polytheism right  the you know to belong to to follow a  club whoever it might be as long as it's  not real Madrid or Manchester United or  Chelsea obviously just everybody hates  is is is to is to belong to that that  sense of who you are and where you're  from and what you stand for and that's  linked to your myths your gods your  history and there are other gods there  are other teams with other gods and  other histories and they are different  and they're the enemy but they have to  be respected too yeah so what I see in  football is a kind of complex  polytheistic structure where I can I can  have a as I do a fanatical devotion to  Liverpool Football Club fanatical  devotion I want them to destroy Real  Madrid on Saturday night but I still  respect the gods of Real Madrid yeah  kind of